manston in Southern England a former air
base housing several thousand recently
arrived refugees and migrants it's not
meant to it's designed for a maximum of
1600 people and they're only meant to
spend a day or two here but many have
been here weeks and at least eight have
reportedly caught diphtheria a highly
contagious virus
some including the local conservative
Member of Parliament are blaming the
conditions on home secretary Sue Ella
bravaman that facility operated
absolutely magnificently and very
efficiently indeed until five weeks ago
when I'm afraid
the Home Secretary took the policy
decision not to commission further
accommodation that's a claim Braverman
Rejects
when we face so many arrivals so quickly
it is practically impossible to procure
over a thousand beds at such short
notice
consequently we have recently expanded
the site and are working tirelessly to
improve facilities the British
government says about 1500 people cross
the English Channel from France in small
boats over the weekend and the total
this year is around forty thousand one
reason for the increased backlog at
processing centers is the rising Asylum
applications this year's already seen 63
000 far more than the whole of last year
but nowhere near the record of 84 000
reached in 2002. now on Tuesday the
Chief Inspector of Prisons whose remit
also takes in Immigration detention
centers releases a report on manston
saying the following the home office and
contractors need to get a grip they need
to speed up the processing of migrants
they need to make suitable Provisions so
people can be moved off-site as quickly
as possible and housed in Humane and
decent conditions clearly the pressure
on the government is growing hundreds
more people will move to manston on
Sunday after a man threw petrol bombs at
a Migrant Center in Dover before killing
himself Charities working with Asylum
Seekers say the system needs a total
overhaul legal routes and actually
giving people the chance to prove that
actually yes they are
legitimate refugees
then I think that would clear up a lot
of the problem and it would take the
money away from the human traffickers
Sue Ella bravaman's also Under Pressure
because she sends official documents to
her private email six times she resigned
on the previous prime minister Liz
truss's government but was reappointed
by Regis sunak just days later one
conservative ex-minister says if she did
refuse to deal with overcrowding here
then she broke the ministerial code and
should step down Nadine barber Al
Jazeera in Southern England